Yes.
You probably already know. Uh,
I finally got a software engineering job now I'm super grateful and
super relieved that I don't have to interview anymore. I mean,
interviewing is super stressful and it's not that fun.
Like I really hate interviewing well, I mean,
actually I think I hate before interviewing,
cause that's when you get the most stressed,
but then when you're interviewing and if you're actually doing really well,
it actually feels kind of good. It feels kind of good,
but I'm glad I don't need to lead code anymore. I mean,
I did it so much that it kind of became a habit every day.
I just go home li code a little bit and a part of me kind of
a part of me kind of wants to just continually coding every day,
just to keep my skills fresh, my interviewing skills fresh, you know,
you never know if you want to switch jobs or not.
So the reason why I didn't say anything for the longest time is because I didn't
want to jinx it.
I wanted everything to be confirmed and finalized before telling you,
but, uh, yeah, I've been working for a few weeks now and um, yeah,
it seems okay. I think I got the job for sure now,
so I can tell you guys now, so due to privacy concerns, um,
I'm not gonna share which company it is. Um, maybe once I quit,
I can share which company it is, but, um, you know,
I don't plan on quitting anytime soon,
but I can tell you that the company is part of Fen.
Good Todd, good Todd.
I'm incredibly happy that I got this job offer. Uh,
I'm actually really grateful and um, yeah,
like it's always kind of been my dream job back then and uh, yeah,
so for, for transparency sake, uh,
I have a total compensation of 278,000 for the first year.
And then in the later years, it's less than that because I had a sign-on bonus.
So I want to tell you exactly how I transitioned from data scientists to
software engineer from the day that I wanted to switch to software
engineering.
So I was still at Facebook when I decided to transition into software
engineering. I talked to my friends, uh,
one of them was a data engineer who switched into software engineering to
get some info. I asked them about different companies,
what the culture was like, um,
what kind of questions they ask during interviews? What was the pay?
How long does it take for the recruiters to respond back?
What tech stack they use, et cetera, et cetera.
So I was just gathering information.
So I kind of already had a list of companies that I wanted to apply to during
the same week I refreshed my Python skills. I mean,
I haven't coded in like forever.
I think the last time I coded was during my internship at LinkedIn,
which was winter 2015. I used two before,
but I decided to relearn or slash learn Python three just because it's newer.
And it's almost the same thing except for a few little syntax differences.
So I had to relearn how Python does their list, comprehensions array, strings,
Lambdas, their syntax for dictionaries, their string stuff.
And also like common libraries that we would usually use in a coding interview.
So that took me about two days. Yeah.
Then I started li coding and I actually just focused on the easy
questions and the reason why is because I couldn't even do them.
So I wouldn't even try to do the medium questions until I could flash the easy
questions by the way, no one uses the term flash. Uh,
I use the term flash because in a bouldering,
when you flash a climate means you did it in one shot.
So for interviews, I mean for interview questions, I say,
you flashed a question if you just run it once and you get it on your first try
without looking at the answers.
So I did about 30 to 40 easy questions before I can actually flash
these easy questions. And that took about two to three weeks, not bad.
I did like one to two questions a day. I was slowly practicing.
I mean, I still had a full-time job, so I didn't have that, that much time.
I was also kind of sad at that time.
So I exercise a lot to try to cope with that.
And that also took away from my coding time failing these legal question.
Really. Wasn't great for my self-esteem. Especially at the beginning,
when I was failing all of these questions, it, it felt pretty bad.
I mean, like my self-esteem was pretty low. And then in addition,
you have to grind these questions and every question that you miss, you just,
Oh, you're a failure. So it was kind of hard in the beginning,
but in the end it was worth it. After that,
I started doing medium questions now to this day.
I don't think I can flash medium questions. I mean, they're pretty hard.
Some medium questions are a lot easier than others. Uh,
it really depends because it kind of depends on your strengths and your
weaknesses. Some of them I could flash, but some of them, I cannot,
I can't even solve them. So it's kind of hard to say,
but I still did a lot of them.
And then the more you do that use your debit card. In the meantime,
I decided to actually start applying to jobs because I told myself that I needed
to put deadlines because without deadlines,
I'm just going to Slack and I'm not going to practice seriously.
So I polished my resume because my resume was kind of built in a more data
science PME role.
So a lot of the bullet points I had to change to make it more software related.
For example, for my data science job,
I would focus more on the data engineering aspect of the job.
And then for my PM experience,
I would talk about how I prototyped these products,
which requires coding so that I could present it to clients and stuff like that.
Getting interviews was actually really easy for me because I've built a
foundation ever since I started doing internships.
So over the course of all those internships, I've built connections, friends,
you know, and whole network of recruiters slash friends.
So for literally any tech company,
I have at least a friend who works there or a recruiter that I can contact
because I've already interviewed there for internships.
The reason why I can contact these recruiters is because back then when I was
interviewing for internships, uh, I actually got offers from them.
And because they remember me,
they'll answer my email and they'll give me at least a phone interview. So yeah,
Waterloo's this because you get a whole network of tech professionals,
you'll get a referral for any company.
Do you want to apply for as long as you made friends back in college and I don't
want to brag, but I had a handful of friends in college.
So I wanted to study full-time and go ham on the coding because I knew that
getting the interviews was not my problem.
My problem was actually passing the interview.
So I decided to quit my job and Lee code full-time,
but that didn't happen.
I ended up doing YouTube a lot and I pretty much studied the same amount as
before. Okay. Maybe not the same amount, but just a little bit more.
So I studied about like two to four hours a day,
which means like three to five questions.
I usually do about three to five questions per day.
And then maybe on the weekends, slightly more, maybe five hours.
I was getting more and more familiar with the questions I was recognizing the
patterns I was learning the tricks. Right.
And it's not even about intelligence or, or being smarter or anything.
It's literally just practice because the questions end up looking the same,
the only change the context or the wording or the storyline behind it.
But it's essentially the same thing.
So four weeks later I had my first phone interview and,
uh, I passed almost all of them because it's, they're, they're not super,
super hard. It's only like a first smokescreen.
And most of the time you might get a question that you've seen already on Lee
code. So that makes it a lot easier. It's technically kind of cheating,
but whatever, after the phone interviews,
I also asked to push the on-site interviews as far as possible because I just
wasn't confident in myself yet. So I wanted more time to study.
So I did like 150 to 200 questions by then,
but I didn't feel like I was getting that much better.
So I bought the book elements of program. Oh, we, I think I have it.
So I bought the book elements of programming interviews in Python because I
wanted to practice coding using a pen and paper,
unlike using a computer and the platform,
because that is a lot more similar to when you're asked the question
using a whiteboard during interviews.
I think it's similar to hard mode when you use pen and paper to write your
code because you have to be a lot more thoughtful because you can't erase.
Then during real interviews,
I actually have a whiteboard and I could use the eraser.
It's going to feel a lot easier.
So two or three days before the onsite interview, I would stop doing YouTube.
And now I would study all day for three days,
I would order delivery so that I don't waste time.
So I would study around 10 to 12 hours per day. Before the interview,
I would do a combination of lead code and paper coding using elements of
programming interview.
I would also go to Glassdoor to look at the interview question for that specific
company and do them.
I also ask around my friends to see what kind of questions they got during their
interview. Usually the questions won't be the same,
but at least you get a sense of what the company's like to ask. For example,
Facebook, they don't ask dynamic programming questions, but Google,
they love to ask the NAMIC programming questions.
If I learned that the company asks system design questions,
then I would go read grokking the system design interview.
And I would just try to, you know, take everything in and hope that I remember.
So at that point I've done around 230 questions on the code and I don't know how
many I've done on pen and paper.
I actually overstudied because there were so many things that I practice for
that I didn't use. Like for example, union find for disjoint sets.
I didn't use that.
Um.
Sorry. I can't think of any examples. Um,
I've already forgotten everything I've learned because I already got an offer,
so I don't get, so yeah,
I passed few of those interviews and I felt some of them and then using
the offers,
I kind of negotiated so that my TC will go up and then until no one can increase
anymore. I just accepted the offer saying it. Now it doesn't sound like much.
It's just study and that's it. But while I was studying,
Holy, I felt like.
But I was lucky that I had roommates and friends to support me when I
most need them to tell me that I'm being too hard on myself to calm me
down. And also thanks to tech lead.
He actually coached me along the way.
And whenever I felt or whenever I needed mock
interviews, he was always there. Now I know in our video,
sometimes it looks like we hate each other.
Some people don't realize those are jokes,
but I've actually grown quite close to him,
especially for the fact that he helped me, not just for the interviews,
but just in general for my mental health. So tech lead,
I know you're watching and I made this collage for you.
This California weather, it's like 90 degrees.
It's making me hot and he has the same effect on me.
It's just so dumb about the way that he's making me feel my insights around.
I just want to shout his name. Uh,
my body's given up on me cause I don't know what to do with my fingertips.
Uh, I want to run through his hair, but I'm trying not to stare.
Now.
I know that I'm incredibly lucky to have guidance and I already have so
many connections in the industry already, but even then,
I don't think I could have persisted without the support of my friends and
tech lead.
So I really don't think that people should go through the interview cycle alone.
That's why tech lead. And I, we worked really,
really hard on this program called tech interview pro.com.
And we want you guys to not be alone during this process.
It's a video course and a community where we all learn how to get jobs at these
big tech companies and supporting each other while we do it.
It's a small group so that technically,
and I can put a lot more time helping people in the program.
We get to answer your questions during our live sessions.
And we also have a lot of code sessions where we showed you how to solve the
most popular questions that are asked by Fang. Anyways, if you're interested,
check out tech interview pro.com, uh, I'm super psyched about the program.
I'm actually really, really happy that we did this. But other than that,
I kind of just wanted to say again that thank you for understanding when I was
away from YouTube for so long.
And thank you for everyone who sent all these positive messages to me,
encouraging me to find a new job in software engine.
I really, really appreciate that. Thank you so much.
I love you.
It's a new chapter in my life. I think it's a pretty good start.